ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูน้องหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ผู้หญิงคะวันนี้เราพบกันที่ช่องไหนคะเรา
พบกันที่ช่อง competency เบิ้ลไทยค่ะค่ะ
นะคะช่องคอมพิวเตอร์ label ไทยเออครูหญิง
คะเอ่อวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันนี้วันศุกร์วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 11 ค่ะวันที่ 11 นะคะ 1
1  11 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
มีนาคมค่ะเดือนมีนาคมแต่ปีนี้ปีพตเท่า
ไหร่แล้วคะดีผช
2565 ค่ะปีพ.ศ
2565 บ้านทีพูด 2,000
565 ได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะงานนะคะวันนี้วัน
ศุกร์นะคะวันที่ 11 นะคะแล้วเวลาขัดตอน
นี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา
16:20  3 นาทีค่ะครูเอ๋ตอนนี้เวลา
16:20  3 นาทีนะคะโอเคค่ะผู้หญิงเดี๋ยว
จะเอาเสร็จนครวันนี้นักเรียนของเราอีก 8
คนมามาแล้วมาครบไหมคะง้อผู้หญิงดูนะคะมี 1
3  4  5  6  7  8 มาครบ 8 คนค่ะครูเอ๋มา
ครบ 8 คนนะคะ
เราจะมีนักเรียนคนที่ 9 ไว้เนาะ
อาจจะต้องหล่อรอนะคะถ้านักเรียนอยากเป็น
นักเรียนคนที่ 9 คอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะ
คอมเม้นข้างล่างมาฟังภาษาไทยมามาเรียน
ภาษาไทยกับครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงแล้วก็ครูเอ๋นะคะ
อาหารนักเรียนผู้หญิงจำได้ไหมอ่ะนักเรียน
นักเรียนชื่ออะไรบ้างนะจำได้จำไม่ได้อ่ะ
นักเรียนอเมริกาค่ะ
นักเรียนอเมริกาเนี่ยมี
สองคนค่ะเป็นผู้ชาย 2 คนค่ะนักเรียนอ่ะ
อังกฤษมีกี่คนคะนักเรียนอังกฤษ 1 คนค่ะ
นักเรียนอเมริกา
2 คนนักเรียนเรียนที่มาจากมาจากประเทศ
อังกฤษกี่คนคะ
1 คนค่ะนักเรียนที่มาจากประเทศญี่ปุ่น
กี่คนคะ
1 คนค่ะคนนะคะแล้วนักเรียนที่มาจาก
ประเทศอินเดียกี่คนคะ
1 คนค่ะนักเรียนที่มาจากที่ประเทศ
ไต้หวัน
กี่คนคะ
1 คนค่ะนักเรียนที่มาจากประเทศเกาหลีกี่
คนคะ 1 คนค่ะก่อนนะคะนักเรียนที่มาจาก
ประเทศอินดิอินเดียไปหรือยังอ่ะสวีเดนกี่
คนคะ
1 คนค่ะอ๋อทั้งหมดกี่คนทั้งหมด 1  2  3
4  5  6  7  8  8 คนค่ะมีนักเรียนนัก
เรียนนักเรียน 8 คนนะคะค่ะ 7 ประเทศราคา 7
ประเทศเหมือนเดิมนะคะมีคุณแรกคุณโรเบิร์ต
คุณทาดาชิคุณ John ชูเมกเกอร์ถ้าคุณลิซ่า
คุณอะไรนะคุณอินเดียกูเอกจำไม่ได้คุณ
ประวีณาคุณประวีณาแล้วก็มิสเตอร์เกาหลี
คุณแจฮีคุณแตฮีแล้วก็มิสเตอร์สวีเดนคุณ
John เหมือนกันนอนนะคะ
โอเคค่ะเรามีนักเรียน 8 คนนะคะ 8 คน
เหมือนเมื่อวานค่ะนะอ่าแล้วบอกเหมือน
เมื่อวานเท่ากับเท่ากับเมื่อวาน
โอเคผู้หญิง
เออนักเรียนมาจาก 7 ประเทศ
รักเป็ดประไทยค่ะ 7 ประเทศครูอยู่ประเทศ
อะไรครูมาจากประเทศอะไรครูมาจากประเทศถ้า
ใครมาจากไหมไม่นะไม่รู้อยู่ประเทศไทย 5
ครูไม่ได้มาจากประเทศไทยคู่อยู่อยู่
ประเทศไทยเองครูหญิงประเทศไทย
ประเทศไทยนะคะประเทศไทยนะใหญ่ไหมคะเล็ก
หรือใหญ่
ไม่ใหญ่
ไม่เล็กนี่เล็กอ๋อไม่ใหญ่ไม่เล็กนะคะ
ประเทศไทยน่ะมีคุยหญิงว่าประเทศไทยได้ไหม
คะได้ค่ะผู้หญิงลบลบนักเรียนก่อนนะคะ
ครูเอะลบมันมีฝุ่นไม่ผู้หญิง
นิดหน่อย
อ้าวประเทศไทยนะคะครูเอ๋
คุยอึ้งวาดใช่ไหมว่านอะไรคะแต่เกรงว่า
ประเทศแผนที่ประเทศไทยค่ะผู้หญิงวาด
แผนที่
ประเทศไทย
สวย
ผู้หญิงครูเอ๋มีคำถาม
ผู้หญิงมีคำถามอะไรคะเช็ค
เช็ควันนี้คู่หญิงอ่า IQ โอเคไหมโห
เฮ้ย
โอเคมั้ยน้องเคตื่นใหม่เถอะง่วงนอน
ใช่ๆต้องต้องรอแล้วโอเคค่ะได้ค่ะกูคำถาม
คือประเทศไทยน่ะมีกี่จังหวัดซ้อนเทศไทยมี
77 จังหวัดค่ะ 5  77 จังหวัดนะคะอ่ะแต่
ว่าที่ครูเอ๋อยากรู้
ที่จังหวัดอะไรนะอ่าจังหวัดอะไรอ่ะเป็น
เมืองหลวง
เป็นเมืองหลวงค่ะจังหวัดอะไรคะ
จังหวัด
กรุงเทพมหานครจังหวัดกรุงเทพมหานคร
ยาวมากนะมึงมีสั้นๆไหมคะครูเอ๋
กรุงเทพฯขอโอเคจังขยายไม่ได้นะคะชุด
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงว่าไม่ใช่ของติวเตอร์
ขยะเล็กๆขยายไม่ได้ค่อยได้ต้องอีกแล้วนัก
เรียนโอเคโอเคอ๋อบางทีเราถามว่าผู้หญิง
เมืองหลวงของประเทศไทย
ประเทศไทยนะคะเมืองหลวงทั่วประเทศไทยชื่อ
อะไรคะเมืองหลวงของประเทศไทยซื่อ
กรุงเทพฯเมืองหลวงของประเทศไทยชื่อ
กรุงเทพราคาออกผู้หญิงไอคิวดีมากขอบคุณ
ค่ะผู้หญิงคะมีนักเรียนน่ะมาจาก 7 ประเทศ
7 ค่ะเพศนะคะครูเอ๋เนี่ยไม่รู้ไม่รู้โค
มะนิวันนี้ง่วงนอนจำไม่ได้เมืองหลวงของ
ประเทศนักเรียน
ไม่ใช่ของไทยนะคะเมืองหลวงของประเทศไทย
ชื่อ
กรุงเทพฯครูเอ๋อยากรู้เมืองหลวงของประเทศ
นักเรียนชื่ออะไร
บ่รู้ไหมลงคุณครูรู้ค่ะครูเอ๋ครูครู
เอ๋ถามครูหญิงได้ไม่ต้องถามนักเรียนถาม
ครูหญิง
ไม่งงมึงถามกูหญิงนะคะ
งั้นกูไอ้ถามกูหญิงนะคะ
อเมริกา
ประเทศอเมริกา
เมืองหลวงชื่ออะไรคะ
ประเทศอเมริกาเมืองหลวงชื่อ
วอชิงตันดีซีไม่ใช่นิวยอร์กหรอ
ไม่ใช่
คู่เอกก็จำว่านิวยอร์กไม่ใช่แคลิฟอร์เนีย
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เท็กซัสไม่ใช่เมืองหลวง
อเมริกาชื่ออะไรนะ
วอชิงตันดีซีเอรายการ DC ขอบคุณค่ะครู
หญิง
เองเอกมีใครอีกครูเอ๋เอ๋อยากรู้ประเทศ
อะไรต่อคะครูเอ๋อยากรู้
ประเทศอินเดีย
บู
อินเดียอินเดีย
เมืองหลวงประเทศอินเดียหรอคะ
มุ่งใบใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่ใช่มุมไบอ้าวแล้วเมือง
หลวงประเทศอินเดียชื่ออะไรคะ
เมืองหลวงประเทศอินเดียชื่อ
นิวเดลีชื่อ
นิวเดลีโอ
โอเคขอบคุณค่ะกูหญิง
พูห์โอ้อยากรู้อีกมีอเมริกา
มีเมืองหลวงชื่ออะไรนะเนื้อชีวิตตันดี.ซี
อินเดียนิวเดลี
อังกฤษค่ะผู้หญิงประเทศอังกฤษเนี่ย
เมืองหลวงชื่ออะไรคะ
ประเทศอังกฤษเมืองหลวงชื่อ
ลอนดอนค่ะเมืองหลวงชื่อลอนดอนออกไม่
อังกฤษเอกก็รู้จักกันเดียวลอนดอน
รู้จักลอนดอนไม่รู้จักกันอื่นนะคะ
โอเคค่ะผู้หญิง
คู๋อยากรู้ประเทศอะไรดีมีประเทศอะไรอีก
แล้ว
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยรู้เมืองหลวงประเทศอเมริกา
เมืองหลวงประเทศอินเดีย
เมืองหลวงประเทศอังกฤษ
ของคุณ John เมืองหลวงของประเทศ
ชื่อเล่นชื่ออะไรคะเมืองหลวงของประเทศ
สวีเดนชื่อ
สตอกโฮล์มค่ะ
Stock บ้านใช้สปาคมขอ
ออกมาเก็บ
เมืองหลวงของประเทศสวีเดนชื่ออะไรนะตัด of
ohm  Stock โคมนะคะ
ก็ยังมีอีกของคุณคุณแทครีมเคแทงมาจาก
ที่ไหนนะมาจากประเทศเตาหลีใต้มาจากเกาหลี
ใต้แล้วเมืองหลวงของเกาหลีใต้ชื่ออะไรคะ
ผู้หญิงเมืองหลวงของเกาหลีใต้ชื่อโซค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เมืองหลวงของประเทศเกาหลีใต้ชื่อ
โซลบางทีพูดกรุงโซลและก็
กรุงเทพกรุงโศก
กะไม่มีครุงวอชิงตันดีซี
ก็พูดได้นะครูเอ๋แต่
วอชิงตันดีซียาวแล้ว
กรุงลอนดอนได้ค่ะกรุงลอนดอนโอเคนะคะ
โอเคค่ะอ๋ออ๋อครูเอ๋รู้จักอเมริกาเมือง
หลวงอเมริกาเมืองหลวงอังกฤษเมืองหลวง
อินเดียเมืองหลวงอาอาเด่นสวีเดนเมืองหลวง
เกาหลีมีอีก 2 ประเทศ
[เพลง]
เสี่ยวหลงเป่าเอ้าประเทศไต้หวันไม่ใช่
เมืองหลวงของประเทศไต้หวัน
ชื่ออะไรคะผู้หญิงเมืองหลวงของประเทศ
ไต้หวันชื่อไทเปค่ะไทยฮะไทยไทยเป้อา
ชื่อไทย
ไทเปโอเค
คนไทยเนี่ยออกเสียงไทเปแต่ไม่รู้ไต้หวัน
พูดอะไรคนไหนพูดไทเปนะคะๆโอเค
เนี้ยผู้หญิงคะแล้วประเทศสุดท้าย
ประเทศญี่ปุ่นครูหญิงเนี่ยคิดว่าครูเอ๋
เอ๋รู้ค่ะว่าเมืองหลวงของประเทศญี่ปุ่น
ชื่ออะไรคะครูเอ๋เมืองหลวงของประเทศ
ญี่ปุ่นผมชื่อชื่ออังกฤษเท่ๆชื่อตื่นเต้น
ตื่นเต้นอื้ออื้อ
โตเกียว
เห้ย
โตเกียวปิ้งป๋องไหม
มัน Mini หานี่น่ะปิ้งต้องก็คือ
เมืองหลวงของประเทศญี่ปุ่นชื่อ
กรุงโตเกียวค่ะ
พูดโตเกียวโอเคพูดกรุงโตเกียวโอเคนะคะ
ขอบคุณนักเรียน 8 คนบ่ใช่เออโอ้โหครูหญิง
เก่งมากนะคะเออปรบมือเลยให้กูหญิงนะคะ
วัยรุ่น
ผู้หญิงคะ
ครูเอ๋ยามั่ว
นักเรียนมามาที่ 7 ประเทศคู่เอ๋แจงลบ
นักเรียนครูเอ๋ก็รู้แล้วแต่คู่เอ๋ไม่รู้
นักเรียนมาจากเมืองอะไรเอาแล้วต้องทำยัง
ไงคะครูเอ๋มีกระดาษกระดาษอีกแล้วเมื่อวาน
ครูเอ๋มีมีกระดาษได้เกรงมีกระดาษพับเบอร์
OA มีกระดาษนะคะอ่าอยากรู้นักเรียนมาจาก
เมืองอะไรนะคะนักเรียนเขียนได้ไหมเขียง
คู๋คู๋มาจากเมืองเมืองอะไรอ่ะกูเองอยู่
อยู่ๆนะคะโอเคอยู่
กรุงเทพฯนะคะค่ะอ่ะอา
กูเออยู่
กรุงเทพฯค่ะผู้หญิงมัน
ครูหญิงอยู่
อุ้ย
กรุงเทพฯค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงก็อยู่
กรุงเทพฯนะคะ
นักเรียนอะตอนนี้นักเรียนอยู่
เมืองอะไรอยู่เมืองอะไรนะแกงเมืองอะไรแต่
ถ้าเราถามเราก็ถามมาจากเมืองอะไร Rings
อยู่อันนี้ Online
Online ต้องถามนักเรียนอยู่เมืองอะไร
ถ้านักเรียนมา
กรุงเทพฯครูเอ๋จะถามนักเรียนมาจากเมือง
อะไร
แต่ตอนนี้นักเรียนอยู่อยู่อเมริกาอยู่
อังกฤษแต่อยู่ญี่ปุ่นอยากรู้นักเรียนอยู่
เมืองอะไรราคา 3 แตะนักเรียนรู้แล้วครู
หญิงกับครูเอ๋อยู่
กรุงเทพฯค่ะอยู่เมืองหลวงครูเอ๋เอ๋เขา
อยู่เมืองหลวงนะเดี๋ยวครูหญิงดูได้ไหมคะ
ว่านายค่ะเมืองอะไรราคาขายค่ะครูเอ๋อยาก
รู้
ใครก่อนคะ
[เพลง]
อเมริกาก่อนเลยค่ะ
อเมริกามีสองคนอเมริกันอีมีคุณแบรดคลิปหา
อยากรอบคุณจอนจอนชูเมกเกอร์นะคะในพีครู
เอ๋อยากรู้
คุณแบรดพิตต์ค่ะ
เป็นแร็พถ้าคุณแบรดพิตต์ราคาอยู่ประเทศ
อเมริกาเมืองหลวงชื่อว่าชิงตันดี.ซีคุณ
แบรดพิตต์อยู่ที่ไหนคะ
คุณแรกพิษยกแล้วค่ะคุณแรนคุณแบรดพิตต์บอก
ว่ากรุงเทพคุณแบรนด์ฮะกรุงเทพฯไหมคะไม่
ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่คุณแรกพิษอยู่อเมริกาค่ะอยู่
อเมริกาค่ะคุณแพ้พิษบอกว่า
คุณแรกพิษเขียน 2 ค่ะครูเอ๋ทำไม 2
อ๋ออ๋อครูเอ๋
อเมริกาเนี่ยใหญ่ค่ะ
อเมริกาใหญ่คักใจมากๆแล้วก็อเมริกาเนี่ย
อันนี้เอ่ออันนี้กูหญิงว่าอเมริกานะคะค่ะ
หานี้อเมริกาอ่ะมีอะไรกับ
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้
ผู้หญิงวาดว่าอะไรนะคะอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไร
คะวาดแผนที่อเมริกาค่ะแผนที่อเมริกาเเละ
แค่นี้อเมริกาใหญ่ใช่มั้ยใหญ่มากใช่อัน
นี้ประเทศใช่ไหมครับประเทศอเมริกาจ่ายค่ะ
เล็กลงมาเป็นอะไรคะเป็นรักค่ะรัฐอเมริกา
มีกี่รัฐพระคะนี้นี่
ค่า 10 รัฐค่ะอเมริกามี 50 ล้านนะคะ
แล้ว 1 รุ่นใหญ่ไหมกูนี่นะเอามาประเทศ
อเมริกาก็ใหญ่ห่า 1 รัฐก็ใหญ่
แล้วใน 1 รัฐมีเมืองมืองอ.เมืองเมืองอีก
ใช่ไหมคะตายค่ะครูเอ๋คุณแร้คพิษก็เลย
เขียนสองอย่างเขียนว่าอะไร
คุณและพิษบอกว่าคุณแบรดพิตต์อยู่รัฐ
แคลิฟอร์เนียขอรัฐแคลิฟอร์เนียน่าอยู่
เมือง LA อ๋อ
[เพลง]
LA
รัชนีฟอเนียแล้วก็ LA เมืองหนึ่งเมืองใน
แคลิฟอร์เนียไปค่ะครูเอกก็คิดรัฐ
แคลิฟอร์เนีย Last ลอสแองเจลิสไม่ใช่ไม่
ใช่ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
ลอสแองเจลิสอยู่ในรัฐแคลิฟอร์เนียค่ะขอ
ขอบคุณค่ะคุณแม้พิษนี้นะคะ
คุณแบรดพิตต์มาอยู่ที่
รัฐ
แคลิฟอร์เนียถูกมั้ยหาจุดที่เมือง
ลอสแองเจลิส
เลเกชายจะจำได้ไหมครูเองจดได้ไหมคะได้หา
กูอะเขียนค่ะเขียนเอาไว้จะได้จำได้คุณ
แบรดพิตต์อยู่รัฐอะไรอยู่เมืองอะไร
โอเคนะคะ
แล้วคุณ John ชูมัคเกอร์นะคะคุณ John
เนี่ยคุณ John เขียนคุณจอนอยู่รัฐเท็กซัส
อเมริกา
ใหญ่
อ๋ออยู่รัฐเท็กซัสป่า
เมืองอะไรคือคุณ John เขียนเมืองฮูสตัน
ค่ะ
มึงเล่าสั้นหรอคนไทยพูดฮูสตันเนาะกูสตัน
ใช่นักเรียนโอเคมั๊ยเจ๊กันบอกขาไทยภาษา
ไทย
ก็คุณจอห์นมาจากเมืองคูสตั้นนะคะตัน
ไปหวันไต้หวันก็
ผู้หญิงของเรา
คุณลิซ่าคุณลิซ่ามาจากอยู่ประเทศไต้หวัน
นะคะอยู่ประเทศไต้หวันนะคะเมืองหลวงชื่อ
ไทเปแล้วคุณลิซ่ามะอยู่เมืองอะไรคะครู
หญิง
คุณลิซ่าอาอยู่เมืองไทเปค่ะครูเอ๋อยู่
เหรียญหลวง
[เพลง]
อยู่เมืองหลวงเหมือนผู้หญิงกับครูเอ๋เอ๋
อยู่เมืองหลวงอยู่เมืองหลวงนะคะค่ะต่อไป
มีใครอีกคะอ้อมีอะคุณคุณแพ้
คุณแท้ยี่คุณแทฮีเป็นคนเกาหลี
ค่ะเมืองหลวงชื่อกรุงโซลแล้วคุณแทงทีมา
จากเมืองอะไรคะ
คุณจากคุณแท้ที่อยู่ค่ะ
เอกคิดมา
คิดว่ากูเอกคิดนักเรียนมามามาไทยนะอ่ะคุณ
แท้อยู่เมืองอะไรคะผู้หญิงคุณแท้อยู่
เมืองปูซานค่ะ
[เพลง]
ปูซานจะไม่ได้อยู่เมืองหลวงของมากับปู
สร้างสวย
สวยสวยๆๆ
ที่ซีรีส์สวย
แล้ว
มีมีใครบ้างแล้วนะคะมีคุณอีกคุณแปร๊ดคุณ
John คุณลิซ่าคุณแตฮี
โอเคอยากรู้
คุณประวีณา
คุณประวีณาอยู่ประเทศอินเดียเมืองหลวงที่
นิวเดลีและคุณประวีณาอยู่เมืองอะไรคะคุณ
ประวีณาอยู่เมืองนิวเดลีค่ะอ่ะ
ดีขึ้นคุณประวีณาอยู่เมืองหลวงนะคะนี้
อยู่เมืองหลวง
กี่คนละอ่ะกลับไปค่ะครูคุณ
โรเบิร์ตแพททินสัน
คุณโรเบิร์ตคุณโรเบิร์ตอยู่ประเทศอะไรนะ
คะครูเอ๋ประเทศอังกฤษเมืองหลวงชื่อกรุง
ลอนดอนช้าผู้หญิงแล้วหากลโรเบิร์ตอยู่
เมืองอะไรคะลองดอกมั้ยไม่ใช่ค่ะคุณโร
เบิร์ตอยู่เมืองลิเวอร์พูลคุณระเบิดอยู่
เมืองลิเวอร์พูลฟุตบอลใช่ไหม
บอลเราพูดฟุตบอล
นักเรียนพูดฟุตบอลไหมมีลูกบอลคะ
แล้วก็เดี๋ยวนะงั้นคุณเอ๋
กูไอ้นี่แค่ผู้นะคะเก๋
อาจาร์ยบีฟุตบอล
อ๋อครูเอ๋รู้จักลิเวอร์พูลเพราะว่าฟุตบอล
โอ้ย Robert พิมพ์เลยค่ะ
[เพลง]
ครูเอ๋แต่คุณโรเบิร์ตไม่ได้อยู่เมืองหลวง
ขอคุณระเบิด
ลิเวอร์พูลไม่ใช่เมืองหลวงเนาะไม่ทรายลำ
ฎอนเป็นเมืองหลวงนะคะแล้วก็เหลืองคุณ
John
คุณ John เหมือนกันเอ่ออยู่ประเทศสวีเดน
อยู่ประเทศสวีเดนเมืองหลวงชื่อสตอกโฮล์ม
ผู้หญิงแล้วพี่จอนอยู่เมืองอะไรคะ
คุณจอนอยู่เมืองสต๊อกโฮล์มค่ะคุณจอนอยู่
เมืองหลวง
อยู่เมืองหลวงนะคะ 3
ผู้หญิงคนสุดท้าย
คุณทาดาชิคุณทาดาชิ
คุณทาดาชิอยู่ที่ประเทศญี่ปุ่นอยู่ประเทศ
ญี่ปุ่น
เมืองหลวงชื่ออะไรครูหญิงวิธีโตเกียวค่ะ
ลงโตเกียว
ชิคู่เอกคิดไม่ต้องเขียนนะคะไม่น้ำ
เกียรติรู้ a รู้หรอคะว่าว่าคุณทาดาชิ
อยู่เมืองอะไร
คุณดาทาดาชิพูดนิดหน่อยแล้วก็
เอา
คุณตาอาชิ
อยู่
เมืองเกียวโตใช่ไหมคะ
คุณธนาชิพยักหน้าง้อคนไทยพยักหน้าให้
ขยะหน้าใช่สายหัวไม่ใช่นะคะหนึ่งนักเรียน
นะถ้าใช่นักเรียนพยักหน้าไม่ใช่น่ะรัก
ปลายหัวหรือมือก็ได้ไม่ใช่อ๋อเขาจะแย่อ่ะ
กูเองดาวน์ถูกๆครูเอ๋รู้ได้ยังไงอ่ะดูจาก
อะไรคะว่าคุณทาดาชิอยู่เมืองเกียวโตเพื่อ
ไอคิวดีเอาค่ะออกเมื่อวานเมื่อวานครูเอ๋
คลาสเซทคุยถามทาดาชิรับมาจากที่ไหน
จองอยู่อยู่ไหนคุณทานอาชีพบอกครูเอ๋ม้า 1
อยู่ที่เกียวโตนะคะคุณทาดาชิไม่ได้อยู่
เมืองหลวง 5 เมืองหลวงชื่อ
โตเกียวจากคุณธนาชิอยู่เกียวโตราคา
ก็วันนี้เราก็รู้ใช่ไหมคะผู้หญิงอ่ะเรา
รู้นักเรียนอยู่เมืองอะไรนะคะเราก็วันนี้
นักเรียนก็รู้จักประเทศ
ประเทศอะเมืองหลวง
เมืองหลวงเมือง
ณเมืองอะไรนะคะอาหารอ่อนแล้วก็รู้จัก
อเมริกาในใหญ่
ฉฉมีรัฐคะแล้วก็มีมือเมืองนะคะเมืองแต่
ของคุณทาชินิดจังหวัดนะอ๋ออ๋อจังหวัดใช่
ไหมจังหวัดอ่ะอะเกียวโตค่ะจังหวัดนะจ๊ะ
จังหวัดเกียวโตเหมือนเราจังหวะตะลุงเทพ
ธนาคารกลางกรุงเทพฯเป็นเมืองหลวงนะคะโอ้ว
ผู้หญิงอะไรคะหมดเวลาแล้วอ่ะโอเคไม่เป็น
ไรค่ะเพราะวันนี้เราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อน
บ๊ายบายไปแล้วค่ะค่ะแล้วเจอกันนะคะบ๊าย
บายบ๊ายบายค่ะ